why Ariana Grande pulled out of a
surprise Brits tribute and as ed Sheeran
fuels rumors he's already married Liam
Payne shuts down rumors of a split plus
Zayn Malik teases new music everyone
Denny here now tonight is the 2018 Brit
Awards which is the UK's equivalent of
the Grammys and Britain's biggest stars
crushed the red carpet at London's Royal
Albert Hall Justin Timberlake do a Lipa
Sam Smith all expected to perform but so
when you won't see at the Brits ariana
grande re was set to pay tribute to the
victims of the Manchester bombing which
took 22 lives outside her concert last
year but we're told she had a pull out
of the surprise tribute performance due
to health reasons that kept her from
actually flying a source tells et ariana
fell ill and was going to come in spite
of that but was ordered by her doctor to
not fly you'll remember re put together
the one love Manchester benefit concert
after the terror attack and that concert
raised nearly three million dollars for
the Red Cross fund to help victims
families meanwhile can we talk about how
the girl has been missing from social
media
she hasn't posted anything on Instagram
or Twitter since this cryptic New Year's
Eve post which just teased see you next
year hopefully that means Ariana has
been in the studio cooking up a
dangerous woman follow-up back to the
Brit Awards red carpet though whereas
Sheeran is fueling rumors he's already
married we already knew that the British
crooner was engaged to cherry C born but
he was spotted again wearing a ring on
that finger at the BRIT Awards and fans
are wondering if he tied the knot in
secret et has reached out to Ed's camp
no response yet but it is clear it's
found the one his last album divided was
about his longtime love who he's known
since they were 11 which for Edie means
she keeps him grounded
meanwhile Liam Payne hit the Brit Awards
red carpet as well looking also dapper
alongside baby mama and a fellow singer
Cheryl Cole that has one good-looking
couple and despite their 10-year age
difference it looks like they're going
strong the two have been at the center
of rumors that they are calling it quits
and addressing those reports head-on
Cheryl told BBC yesterday rumors about
her relationship don't bother her in
fact her focus right now is on her
charity campaign well let me tell you if
this video backstage at the Brits is any
clue these two look pretty spin to me
look how cute all right guys moving on
to Liam's former bandmate Zayn he's been
busy sending fans into a frenzy sharing
snippets of his new music
[Music]
oh you sound good there Zane he still
looked good too look at him right there
all right the man hasn't dropped a full
album since 2016 mind of mine and the
new stuff sounds even more soulful than
that debut release Zane's girlfriend
Gigi Hadid gushed about Zayn sound to ET
back when that album dropped take a look
yeah and it's a beautiful thing to see I
think you know the more that he's on his
own the more that he's finding like you
said the soul in the music and what's
making him really happy to sing and and
genuinely makes him want to be on stage
so you know the music that he's starting
to do more now is it's just showing how
much more he's learning about himself so
what do you guys think of Zane's
mysterious track or even tracks are you
liking the direction this has headed see
what I did there okay I'll see myself
out but before I go be sure to like and
share this video and then come back
tomorrow cool I'll see you then